[Music]
okay who who wants to start it off i
just do as i'm told i'm a guy that
reacts some say i'm a nuclear reactor
let's begin how do we want it do we talk
over the clip or let the clip play
over it
let's talk over it the less i hear my
own voice the better you know what it's
like to be me
okay i'll do as i'm told i'm going to
suggest girly you take charge maybe for
the first time in your life let's do it
okay you got it well this is exciting
because sona you have your own new
series on the team coco youtube channel
wait you've already had this hold on
what this is this is very exciting
because sona a new season of your series
let's try it one more time
it's on youtube but it was on instagram
before right oh i don't know honestly i
hate this so much okay please
yeah let gorley do it and please don't
interrupt girly anyone he knows what
he's doing go ahead girly in three two
and it's all yours this is very exciting
sona because your
web series [ __ ]
oh my god
what is
amazing did you say video series adam is
it a video series i don't even know what
it is okay all right i have a wedding
here we go
you've got to be quiet during this now
please what i
despite everything he's done so far i
still believe in gurley and i think this
is going to be the take in three two one
it's all yours this is very exciting
because sona
a new c
what is your problem i'm sorry he's so
like this is this is really exciting
because
you have
let's try this again and then
two more mistakes like this and i'm
calling uh i'm calling the emt can this
just be the whole segment can we just
stop right here no no i'm sure gurley's
gonna get it okay okay take 15 and go
sona you have a new video series out
sona fixes your life it's the second
scene [ __ ]
why are you explaining to her that she
has a new series because she knows the
listener needs to know
hey
what is that
all you have to do is say well sona i
find this very exciting uh you have a
new series out you know that
you know that's all you have to do it's
not a big deal no this is i hope
by the way this has to air somehow
because um
and i'm not a doctor i am not a
neurosurgeon i know a lot of people
think i am but i think it's a small
bubble of air
that has worked its way into the speech
center
of burley's brain and i think that's
what's causing a complete meltdown girly
no pressure
at all
no pressure
in five four get it right this time
three two it's really on you you have
this has to be good one and you've got
it hi sona your new show on a television
could i do watch it
all right here we go
sona word has it that your series sona
fixes your life
has a new season and the new first
episode is out now i thought we could
take a little
taste of it right now and talk about it
a little bit okay so we're gonna see a
clip from sona's this is her web series
sonic fixes your life yes okay good i
just like to set the table what is your
approach to addressing sex to your
children love you
oh
[Music]
oh what a dick that person's a dick this
is great
hi guys
it's sona
obsession
please
and as you can tell i'm very serious i
have books behind me
i've read every single one
that's a lie
and i have this thing next to me what is
this it's a rocker why do i know that
because i'm a parenting expert now how
am i a parenting expert i have had
children for four months
so obviously i'm an expert that's eight
months so i'm happy to answer all the
questions that you guys have about
parenting so let's raise your kids at
euler 277 says what are your strategies
for keeping conan hey children
uh
just
to a never given my address
b
you know i told him i was pregnant but i
uh
i think that if i just tell him that i
was a pillow the whole time maybe he'll
never show up
why would someone say that why would
someone say keep conan away from your
kids just to never tell them where i
live because then i'll just come and
want to meet them while sona left sona
doesn't like hearing her own voice
and sona i have to say i sympathize
because i don't like hearing your voice
come back in she left the studio during
that i want to say you're very
photogenic
and you uh you look very attractive
thank you that was awful no it was not i
hate you you've got eating that oh stop
it no that's awful i just i hate
everything about uh what we're doing
talking about it listening to it
watching it wow you're the best promoter
of a project
why are we even here if you're just
going to make noises and say don't waste
your time i think that could be very
valuable i'm a little hurt because
a viewer said uh
or listener whatever you want to call
him said how do you keep conan away from
your kids that's insulting i did visit
your children you did and i worked hard
to get some laughs out of them and i you
did uh mikey easy yeah easy laugher
charlie
um i don't know if uh i whatever smashed
his car in a previous life
but he was just staring me down there's
always charlie's going to be that guy in
the audience for the rest of my life who
doesn't give it up i couldn't crack yeah
you kidding crack i couldn't crack
charlie but uh mikey very sweet and uh
was fascinated kept looking up at my
hair well they've never seen anyone like
you before what do you mean you are the
tallest whitest person they've ever met
and your hair is very
can be scary to babies
oftentimes they think it's a mobile my
hair
and they try and bad at it
no but i i visited uh your kids and i
thought i was very good and i was very
impressed with how
adeptly you
and tac your husband handle your kids
because you have twins so each of you is
holding a kid and then you're performing
all these functions around the house
just holding on to a kid yeah so tac was
like oh you want a beer and i'm like
yeah i'll take a beer he went to the
refrigerator and opened the refrigerator
and and got out a beer opened it poured
it into a glass then i think he built a
ship in a bottle
with one hand
and and the whole time holding uh your
son yeah you're doing stuff too you're
painting stuff yeah
you're doing eye surgery on people and
you're holding your other son it's
amazing yeah but we kind of have to
because especially you know we we had a
lot of help and then my parents left for
a week so then we were like oh we
actually have to parent these children
right now why did your parents leave for
a week were they deported no they were
not deported well i'm just curious no
they were not deported do they have
their papers in order oh my god do they
have their papers they do yeah i mean i
did i used to threaten to deport them
when they would upset me i like you're
mad at me for making that joke when you
used to regularly you know what to
deport your
parents when you were a teenager right
yeah when i was a teenager and they'd
upset me i told them i was gonna deport
them they're like we're citizens and i'm
like i'm sure there's a loophole
what sona you need to fix your own life
yeah you're fixing other people's lives
no i love that you're posing on the
balcony of your new home yeah that's
very nice that was so silly i know it
was it's a fun thing to shoot that's all
and it's it's
like i like connecting with your fans
they're your fans that i'm poaching oh i
think they're your fans as well let's be
fair well they're i mean it's off of the
team coco stuff so it is your they are
your fans that's true yes and of course
the house that you're in is paid for by
money what paychecks
employ me and i do a service and then i
get paid for it well i employ you i
don't know what service
you're doing
i can't come in today
uh it's just not a good day for me
where's my check that's my that's my
sewn impression is it it's good yeah you
wanna hear my conan impression
yeah
okay well that's
by the way everyone you're hearing has a
college education
[Laughter]
well congratulations on your series and
best of luck to you sona and stop making
noises and bitching about how you hate
the sound of your voice you've got to
convince people to check this thing out
oh yeah it's good it's good i guess i'll
do it for you sona yeah and this is just
off the top of my head new episodes post
on fridays on team coco's youtube page
and the first episode is out now want to
know how to get your life fixed sona
takes questions from fans via team
coco's instagram stories so be sure to
follow at team coco for the next time we
ask questions okay well if you're making
room for that in your schedule
you don't have a lot going on
i'm sorry but that's just absurd so
you're a great promotion too yeah yeah
i'm creating content for you you're
welcome okay all right yeah i'm sure i'm
sure you're being overly compensated but
anyway
um the important thing is that we're
friends you've got a project and i wish
you all the best
ugh let me just read this note off my
hand and i care for you and respect you
there we go